los virus son interesantes porque son
los piratas robots de la microbiología
en este vídeo vamos a aprender qué es lo
que los hace tan buenos como piratas
robots veamos lo que distingue a los
virus hay cuatro cosas que los
caracterizan lo primero es que son
realmente pequeños así que tenemos el
tamaño los virus tienen este tamaño en
comparación con el tamaño de una
bacteria típica que es cien veces más
grande que un virus imaginen que aquí
estoy dibujando 100 virus en el diámetro
de esta bacteria aunque no lo estoy
dibujando a escala de manera que esta
bacteria es 100 veces más grande y una
célula eucariota típica como las células
humanas no cabría en la pantalla porque
es mil veces más grande formaría un
círculo que ocuparía toda la pantalla si
completará este dibujo que hice en la
esquina aquí estamos hablando de los
diferentes tamaños entre los virus las
bacterias y las células humanas pero hay
otro aspecto en relación al tamaño y es
la diferencia de tamaño de los virus
entre sí hay unos virus más grandes que
otros y es
es una manera de diferenciar a ciertos
virus hay unos virus tremendamente
pequeños otros solo pequeños aquí dibujé
puntos más grandes y más pequeños el
siguiente punto con el que podemos
diferenciar a los virus es su forma
imaginemos que vemos con más detalle a
uno de estos virus para hablar de por
qué tienen la forma que tienen todos los
virus tienen esta cápside que es una
capa de proteína con formas bastante
particulares podemos pensar en los virus
como legos y los llamo legos porque
necesitan estos pequeños bloques básicos
llamados caps o meros para crear su
forma estoy usando estas bolitas para
construirlo y aunque no lo he dibujado
muy bien todos tienen el mismo tamaño
para este virus en particular cada una
de estas cosas es un caps homero y estos
caps o meros forman estas bellas figuras
tridimensionales aunque aquí lo dibujo
en dos dimensiones pueden imaginarse que
esto es un diamante tridimensional de
seis lados y esta configuración se llama
icosaedro
también hay algo que al verlo por
primera vez parece helicoidal pero no
está formado así de hecho hay muchos
monómeros envueltos entre sí casi como
una hélice y luce más como un cilindro
pero como está envuelta sobre sí misma a
esta forma se le llama helicoidal y otra
posibilidad es la forma esférica esta
línea gris que acabo de dibujar es una
cubierta que a veces cubre la cápside y
digo a veces porque no todos los virus
la tienen
está cubierta les da cierta ventaja de
la que hablaremos con más detalle más
adelante cualquiera de estas dos
opciones podría estar dentro de esta
cubierta pueden imaginar la envolviendo
la capa de proteína en un círculo esta
es la forma esférica como si fuera una
pelota estas fueron dos de cuatro cosas
con las que podemos identificar los
virus esta es la tercera y es bastante
clara es la información genética
contenida en los virus el ácido nucleico
hay cuatro opciones los virus son
geniales porque pueden contener un tipo
de ácido nucleico de hecho siempre
contienen
ese tipo ya han visto adn de doble
cadena que es el que se encuentra en la
mayoría de las células humanas también
han visto a rn de cadenas simple como en
el arn mensajero lo que probablemente no
han visto son adn de cadenas simple o
arn de doble cadena esto es lo que hace
únicos a los virus son especiales porque
pueden contener uno de estos tipos de
ácidos nucleicos esta es una forma de
distinguirlos un virus puede tener adn
de cadena simple o un arn de cadena
simple no puede tener ambos y es por eso
que los ácidos nucleicos son la tercera
forma de distinguir a los virus entre sí
esta información genética no puede estar
solamente flotando por ahí de hecho está
empaquetada o almacenada dentro de la
capa de proteína y debido a que estos se
les llama cápside y esto es el ácido
nucleico cuando se unen para formar un
virus que voy a dibujar de forma
simplificada con esta figura hexagonal y
que imaginamos que es un virus de cadena
simple
a esto se le llama núcleo cápside y
nuevamente podría o no tener una
cubierta esta que acabo de dibujar no
tiene cubierta porque no tiene envoltura
externa ahora que ya vimos estas tres
formas de distinguir a los virus entre
sí tamaño o forma ácido nucleico podemos
regresar a pensar en por qué los llamé
piratas robots al inicio del vídeo esta
sería la cuarta característica que nos
permite distinguir a los virus aquí voy
a escribir por el momento piratas robots
y veamos lo que acabamos de mencionar
los virus son realmente pequeños están
compuestos de proteínas sólo tienen un
tipo de ácido nucleico y no tienen
organelos esto quiere decir que ellos no
pueden crear atp o energía para ellos
mismos ni tampoco pueden replicarse por
sí mismos porque no tienen organelos
este es un problema porque todas las
cosas vivas tienen metabolismo
esto se refiere a la parte de robots los
virus se cuelan en células más grandes
que tienen organelos a las que controlan
para hacer copias de ellos mismos
el término oficial para piratas robots
en biología es parásito intracelular
obligado ya que necesita forzosamente
estar dentro de una célula por eso es
intracelular obligado y es un parásito
se apodera de otros seres para
sobrevivir y debido a que necesita hacer
esto seguro que pueden adivinar que la
cuarta característica que distingue a
los virus es el tipo de huésped que
necesitan algo que siempre preguntan las
personas es bueno un virus es
bacteriófago o que es de hecho este es
el nombre de los virus que infectan a
las bacterias y los otros virus que
infectan a las células eucariotas como
por ejemplo las de nosotros los humanos
son todas diferentes en tamaño forma
ácido nucleico y las enfermedades que
causan tienen nombres muy conocidos como
el virus de la viruela o el virus del
herpes el parvovirus y muchos más así
que estos piratas robots se apoderan de
las células usando algunos métodos
especiales que aún no he mencionado y
que tienen que ver con las adaptaciones
de sus formas
tiene sentido porque es la parte
exterior del virus la que entra en
contacto con las células y porque si no
fueran buenos para introducirse en las
células nunca podrían hacer copias de
ellos mismos por lo que como piratas
robots los virus deben hacer algo
especial para introducirse los
bacteriófagos tienen una forma compleja
no son solo helicoidales cúbicos a euros
pueden tener esa núcleo cápside arriba
en la parte superior que contiene el
ácido nucleico pero también tienen una
vaina o envoltura que actúa como una
aguja con la que inyecta su ácido
nucleico y una cola que se adhiere a la
bacteria huésped así que aunque lo he
dibujado así de hecho podemos imaginarlo
adhiriéndose a una bacteria de esta
forma porque la cola la unidad y actuará
literalmente como una aguja para
inyectar a la bacteria voy a usar esta
célula eucariota como un ejemplo para
ilustrar otra forma peculiar que usan
los virus para poder entrar ya que la
célula eucariota que dibuje es tan
grande y su membrana es muy gruesa como
para penetrarla
si el virus no puede inyectar su
material genético como virus complejo
entonces se escabulle y digo que se
escabulle porque cada célula tiene
receptores en su superficie
generalmente receptores normales que las
células necesitan para enviar y recibir
información pero los virus se aprovechan
de eso ya que estos receptores no pueden
diferenciar entre señales normales que
vienen de células normales y señales que
vienen de una célula viral entonces esta
cosa y cosa hedrick o helicoidal llega y
envía señales a estos receptores y los
engaña para que formen este pozo que
finalmente se convertirá en un endoso ma
de manera que el virus se asienta
felizmente dentro habiéndose escabullido
aquí podemos reconocer esto como
endocitosis endocitosis para ingresar a
la célula inventaron este nombre grande
y elegante para algo muy simple el
ingreso a la célula mediante los
receptores endocitosis mediada por
receptor receptores en dos o más y la
razón disimular
porque algunas células tienen estas
cubiertas grises que mencioné al
principio que les dan esta forma
esférica es porque les da una entrada
extra aunque también pueden entrar
mediante la endocitosis mediada por
receptor así que voy a dibujar una línea
gris punteada alrededor de esta área
para que puedan imaginar que si si
tuvieran una cubierta también podrían
entrar de esta manera pero tienen una
opción extra y eso es porque ya tiene
esta burbuja así que envía una señal a
la membrana diciéndole oye me voy a
fusionar contigo me combinará contigo
déjame entrar también se pusieron
elegantes con el nombre que le dieron a
esto ya que se fusiona directamente con
la membrana para poder entrar
se llama fusión directa y ahora tenemos
una idea general de cómo distinguir los
virus y cómo son realmente los piratas
robots del mundo de la microbiología